[Music]
so in haters gonna hate news heinous
submitted by TIFF from Texas news
anchors are facing backlash over their
remarks of that ambitious team mm-hmm
what I say how ambitious and what is the
ambition based on UT it wasn't like a
Mexican kid that said he want to be a
doctor and it's like yeah right
oh wow you're right over there
I'm not saying I said I'm saying did
they say that said it it came out of
your brain though I'm like really fast
yes over there so it's a lot of Mexican
people in Texas Wow
put that together with white racism and
I put that cognitive Wow I know a lot of
Mexican doctors and they all work in
Mexico license yeah
you can't stutter when you're making a
joke like Asian guys have you comedian
or a porn star mm-hmm there are plenty
of patients hey but small tech porn is
also a very pleasurable to watch you
know why because it looks more realistic
it may feel like it's you I did that
before what small tech corner yep
oh wait you did it like you're in it no
I looked for it small big POVs Joe
hasn't searched I know I think I just
want to know the mindset and why so the
POV would have made sense if you were
like yeah POV I'm like okay cuz it's
your own dick you're you're living
vicariously through that I don't
understand
big dick porn you don't understand what
does that what I mean where is it solely
it is to me it's like I'm not watching
porn for the dick I'm watching it for
the woman so when she's getting like so
the big dick upstage is the woman for
you yeah it's - it's like it's kinda
like what rusev honestly I know she's
not enjoying that you're such a liar you
know like that'sthat's kind of like but
then if it's like a it's if it's like a
[ __ ] small little dick like
like this and she's long I love that
[ __ ] I'm off you're so nice and giving
the dick is still upstaging the girls
yeah it sounds like the focus of the day
one is nurturing and then the other one
is rapey some girls like giant penises
yeah maybe that's our thing
no I like I like I like I mean they
don't we don't like I whatever yeah
that's it yeah I think penetration I
like a big dick but then [ __ ] I like
you like big what to view to view watch
because yeah yeah yeah it looks better
because when when when when a guy's
doing doggy style right if the dick is
too small
there's no motion there's nothing
happening it's like it's like this yeah
but if it digs like this you can [ __ ]
see the seesaw motion you know complain
have you ever seen like a round of
applause like this it's not very
exciting you wanna yeah but what the
[ __ ] if the girl is all like and like
this it's like man what the hell you
doing put that whole thing in your mouth
but then it looks like she's about to
choke [ __ ] glimpse of what Holly [ __ ]
suggests you know but but what are you
doing put the whole thing in your mouth
I I can't I can't deny the facts is that
when a girl is working on a very very
very little dick it's so nurturing
looking it just looks like she's such a
giver how you got here from a kid
getting into like accomplished kids you
started it
yeah she started it they were like who's
the weirdo that watches little dick port
and it David say that it's cool nobody
said that you said I searched it you
volunteered it was talked about before
me it was
about that actually talking about here
so there's this kid 17 year old named
Michael Brown he's Michael Brown he went
viral because his so he got accepted
into Stanford and that was like his
dream Wow cool prestigious so this kid
she has a six point four point sixty
eight I was like a six point oh that's
so high four point six eight anything
over a 4.0 is straight A plus extra
credit yeah and he he scored 1540 on the
SAT how many well they moving it back to
1600 I don't know how because it was
going like 2400 for a while right so
that means it's really low
I think he should they're showing you
the contrast of like he's really know
any [ __ ] love yeah if it's for the
new SATs anymore but then that's [ __ ]
high if it's back to the 1600 points
from away from a perfect so apparently a
total maximum you could get a 1600 so
it's back to the original ish yes tight
you got 1540 so that's hella [ __ ]
good yes the video of him getting
accepted you just went viral and then it
turns out that this dude applied to 20
colleges and got into every single one
with the full ride every I know a friend
so then he chose Stanford well the night
guide you've narrowed it down to four
which I'll tell you right now homie
Stanford's a great school but the girls
if you're going for the school that's
cool
but enjoy your college life that's all
I'm saying here genius you're gonna be a
[ __ ] Jesus no matter where you're
going what if one of the school staff
from the other 19 Rock Community
College's then it's not prestigious no
no it's a for every full ride to East LA
Community College the [ __ ] haters go
hey you write counts though because I
have a friend who got accepted to a
couple of Ivy League's but he didn't get
a scholarships from there yeah so he
went to UCLA instead because he gave me
fluoride yeah it's expensive as
expensive
yeah his final four choices are Yale
Georgetown Stanford
in Harvard all must be so hard he has
all his hard he's earned two hundred and
sixty thousand dollars outside of
scholarship money Wow in addition to the
scholarships offered by the school yeah
I would have blown that [ __ ] in Vegas
homie he looks like he could sing oh
yeah he's like a young it's not even
that [ __ ] low-key there's a higher
you look like the genie from Aladdin the
[ __ ] musical hey don't stick me at
your level bro I have some class so you
were going to go to Atlanta you that's
class the opera's class like Aladdin
musicals in Broadway no not that one the
Broadway musical show you guys something
show us then I went to go see cats on
Broadway so these news anchor from DC is
fox news anchors yeah news anchors they
were talking [ __ ] here we go well of
course you guys probably all saw this
student the high school student that
applied to 20 colleges and got into
every single one wow that's insane
they're probably gonna talk about permit
of action how did I go here the highest
voice
do you fund it Yale Harvard Princeton
literally all of them here's a hole to
it this is sort of brought on the to
this it rides to all of them all right
so he has his pick right so it has to
spark the discussion though of how many
schools you should apply taking away
basically everyone applies to a [ __ ] ton
of if you don't you're an idiot yeah cuz
it's expensive a lot of these
universities they they need you to send
in like two three essays let me to go to
in its well here's the thing it's Fox
their narrative is to basically you know
they they really really prey upon the
middle class and poor whites that are
you know so so that's who they're
talking to a lot of bitterness a lot of
people that don't like minorities coming
up or whatever so that's their narrative
that's how they angle a lot of their
discussions and stuff like that maybe
these ladies don't even believe that and
they're not that [ __ ] dumb but that
might be the conversation of the day
yeah so a lot of people were tweeting
one of them is Casey nice that he said
shame on these news anchors he worked
his entire life to achieve the
impossible and instead of celebrating
his extraordinary achievement they chose
to call it ridiculous congratulations
Michael Brown the world needs more
people like you I know it's like someone
that got an Olympic gold medal in 20
sports and instead of like celebrating
the impossible like Casey nice now
saying now you're like oh you just took
away all those Olympic spots for all the
other people even though that even work
like that yeah yeah
that's the funniest [ __ ] there's like
they don't go to that school so that
spots never gonna be filled up you
[ __ ] dumb [ __ ]
you know it's my idiot kid gonna go to
Yale now oh but yeah it follows that it
follows that same narrative of like Oh
affirmative action taking places of like
people that should have been there it's
the same [ __ ] she's probably like kind
of you know basically saying is oh that
he took all these [ __ ] admissions
away when someone else could have been
accepted but that's not how it works
[ __ ] you just get accepted but they're
not guaranteed that you'll start you'll
be there yeah and you won't you're not
gonna be enrolled there's a lot of kids
that get accepted and go I will go this
club grow this school exactly [ __ ]
know that [ __ ] Doug has not accepted in
the Sac State I don't even apply to that
damn school is it a Cal State yeah
they're like you got it and I was like I
never applied I got accepted to Cal
State I am NOT in calcium Long Beach to
9mm apply time for you to enroll on my
way that's exactly why I went to Cal
State LA because I knew I'd get in no
problem
yeah oh I got it you know like it's like
they accepted me the [ __ ] a week
before the semester started Oh
University you're supposed to apply the
year before right that's yeah and then I
was like too late for everything and I
was like [ __ ] I don't want to wait a
whole year to go to you know I was
looking at a Cal State LA after I left
Riverside and I went back to Community
College I wanted to go to a State
University instead of a regular
University and I looked at Cal State LA
I was like oh am I going back to like
the LA area and the dropout rate was so
[ __ ] high it was ridiculous they're
like okay I'll go somewhere else
I went to a sex date instead it's
actually just like actually prettier I
want to you shot for the first two years
that I could I went to Community College
and then I will UCR might as well be a
Cal State not anymore
this is better is yes it's pretty it's a
pretty dope school they have a really
great anthropology business and
med now it's hard to get it to any you
see nowadays yeah well yeah yeah so one
of the anchors the brunette named Sarah
she tweeted out bishops helper I'm sorry
I'm sorry to Michael B I truly had no
malice when I set the story up we wanted
to ask is twenty schools too much but I
see now that it was pick that was petty
Michael is awesome and I have learned a
lesson and my boss frequent flies thank
you for your apology I appreciate it and
accept it but the other chick the blonde
chick Holly
apparently so he says the blonde chick
was the one that was really grinding it
in though Michael tweeted this out he
said this morning I had a respectful
Skype interview with Holly though I did
not get an apology during the interview
I won't allow the interview to air until
Fox 5dc provides me with a public
apology where's the hashtag human
decency that's dope yes so that's the
last I know of this story it seems like
he didn't get it
you should apologize for that [ __ ]
accountability for people being [ __ ]
stupid just for ratings yeah I feel like
every time like my fox news anchors say
something this ridiculous they should
get jumped immediately as as punishment
because it'll teach them a lesson psych
up maybe I shouldn't say that because
I'll get [ __ ] up yep